heute kommen kommentar posten zum ja zum
weltgeschehen überhaupt zur klimakrise
was ist los ist und mit dem ganzen
kroner zeigen und aber jetzt auf ihre
meldung in der zeitung lesen und die
haben jetzt so erschüttert dass ich hab
jetzt wirklich
notfalltropfen immer messen darunter
nämlich an an amanda hat hat er
leberkäse mit kraft und rücken mittel
schaffen sehen von sie hat in süßen senf
tragbar und er hat gesagt er vertraut
bis meter und dann hat der polizei weil
sie nicht er war frisch ist er beginnen
wird und ich weiß nicht wo leben wir
was kommt da ist nix das seiner boncred
streit mit ketchup und greta mayonnaise
das ist korrekt in der le mans